[Musique]
de tellement bien dormir pendant ta
bataille virtuelle ça te branche un
silent disco ce soir et j'ai en train de
manger
seulement pour manger et dormir
il n'y a pas si longtemps les jeux
vidéos étaient commercialisés pour
s'adresser à toute une génération de
garçon oh et aujourd'hui tout le monde
joue 1 2 3 détails oui tu joues au
support alors te plantes pas
tu as encore beaucoup à apprendre tu es
sérieux là je suis assez au niveau
national
je me casse toi on va monter une équipe
entrée
lingue coaching vas-y maman elles ont
besoin de toi franchement elles font
grave pitié
il faut qu'on revienne au fondamentaux
je crois que je vais péter les plombs là
on va s'entraîner mentalement
spirituellement et toi tu fais ça tous
les samedis et physiquement il sentirait
pas le déo de supermarché
vous voulez qu'il soit le plus réaliste
possible barrette ne financera plus
qu'une seule équipe de ESPE donc ce sera
soit vous soit les bêta mais dans ce cas
elle devient quoi ma bourse
de l'annuler
tout le monde voilà les
beaches viens je t'attends oui
t'inquiète le lubrifie vaut mieux je
suis prêt ma grande je suis chaud
bouillante à pas idée de qui t'attend
qu'est-ce qui se passe
bienvenue au championnat national de
Xbox le temps est venu de rallumer la
flamme en vous comme si vous étiez des
enfants c'est soit la victoire soit le
game over
c'est quoi ce truc un poulet
on prend jamais un perso qu'on connaît
pas Lily
en fait j'ai un secret à dire tu peux
t'approcher j'aime le secret
oh non non non